can we do better there's always things
that pop up that we can do better on and
I call the question I'm sorry that's not
how this works we each have an
opportunity to speak five minutes no I'm
sorry that's not how calling the
question works need a second and you to
vote and I have a second are you telling
me that you're gonna keep me from
talking right now you're talking evening
look look here you're calling me
disrespectful because I've interrupted
people but this gentleman has turned off
people's lights in the middle of a
global health pandemic that's what that
gentleman did and you think I'm
disrespectful when you're up thinking a
point of order this gentleman number of
things in large gatherings we could have
closed the beach we could have put a
port or a mean dog hi recess also not
within your power and the attorney has
held that that's true you came up with
new rules at the beginning of the
meeting and then you didn't even want to
follow the rules that you came up with
this is a banana republic is what you're
turning this place into it your
so-called leadership does a recess mean
that we will be yes been talking about
this last week can we calm peoples
utilities this week and made them pay
what could have been their last chat to
us to turn their lights on in the global
health pandemics but you don't care
about that you didn't want to me but
every other year you go around and beg
people for their boats can we explain to
will more about your relationship with
that guy then you care about the
relationship with the people who don't
go to disrespectful is what you've done
the working people in the city you've
failed to act when you're a leader you
failed to act you said you didn't do
anything you failed to act when you had
an opportunity party Christine house
don't care anything about me think
anybody cares you're done you're done
you're done you're done you're done gone
viral yeah there is very little odds of
you getting reelected yeah well we need
folks that are about their constituents
and this lady failed I mean look it's
already a global pandemic people's
anxiety uh people are potentially sick
people are worried people out at work
it's stressful enough as it is
to have to live through that through the
dark I mean I turn my lights off at home
but that's cuz I gotta sleep last night
with me cuz of the dark yeah I don't
like the dark I mean I like it when I'm
sleeping and when I'm you know doing the
grown-up but otherwise I got a
flashlight with me what I'm doing the
grown-up magic myself with a girl
banging and everything's dark he said
yeah I like that like that and I just
turn on the light and flash on my
differently yeah I like that anyways
moving on moving on it's hard we have a
dependent if we don't know what's gonna
happen I stay ready to go so let's go
cuz I don't like the dark see I'm a
really you say you see you don't like
the dark I really don't like the dark I
told you this man doesn't like black
people
Oh
Sam you know hey Sam you know ho ho ho
all right now let's get serious all
right
no no no no don't no hard jokes no
nothing okay we're done
all right we're finished let's get out
of this hole get out of this hole we're
in the hole let's get out of it
it's okay I got a torch Nicholas no pull
that leg pull this [ __ ] back on turn the
flashlight on it they see it what the
[ __ ] is happening why you got a little
random fire I stay ready [ __ ] for what
you don't have been an arson don't put
that [ __ ] on tape because we don't know
stupid don't you huh oh [ __ ] it comes in
a girl I'm gonna give you the fire dicks
like I ain't that good like you yes it
is now I got that flaming fire flame
what else you got in your pockets just
let's stop back to this topic look I
don't know if this man is you know
grandstanding for political purposes
because he's being reelected I don't
know if it's all I don't know I really
don't know what I will say is this he's
still right he's correct at the end of
the day what we know is that he's right
about this situation you cannot in a
time of crisis like this expect people
to be financially solvable people are
living paycheck to paycheck people are
struggling to make ends meet our
government hasn't come together yet to
offer us any kind of financial aid but
unless but it just hasn't happened is
like you know the money will come in
eventually but until then you cannot
afford to turn off people's utilities we
need to keep people warm sanitary so if
you don't keep the utilities on if you
cut the running water by chance then
they can't keep themselves clean so
that right and we also need people to
have their utilities so that they stay
home and so that they don't propagate
this virus you're going to cost
taxpayers far more money if you start
having people having to go on to the
streets and having to start to spread
then if you kept them in and you paid
for it so let's be smart about this
pandemic all right
this ultra capitalism everybody if you
ain't got the money pull yourself up by
the bootstraps mentality it's not what
we need right now for everyone's safety
and for economy be smart unless you
don't think this is a problem and you're
taking this too lightly it shows you
that they don't think that was a problem
maybe when it was when it was happening
to like man whatever it's not a you know
it's not a thing it's gonna go away it's
just a couple of kids is not that bad
let's keep the beaches open we don't
care cuz the week one the week that he's
talking about what he could have these
off that was the week everybody was out
and about on the beaches I think you're
generous I think you're being generous
yes I'm being generous I'm sorry imagine
it looks bad even when I'm generous yeah
I think they know and they do care but
they care more about making money do you
dig what I'm saying possibility it's
their problem
they're gonna die keep the bars open we
got to make our money we need their tax
revenue I gotta pay my salary taxes and
[ __ ] yeah gen IV knife sorry he dies III
think it's just like the people who were
hoarding those masks and then selling
them at up market value and like I
didn't know do you knew what you was
doing yes
these are essential things that people
need for their health and you were
hoarding them and charging them over the
top it's like people who char overcharge
for life-saving medication like what are
you doing in those kind of situations I
want the government to come in and I
want the government to regulate that
that's unacceptable today's you know
that the machine to help heal the
coronavirus right has evolved that is a
thousand dollars hmm and there's a
company that was able to print that
valve for like a buck and of company the
initial company sued them yeah yeah yeah
so what you just see right now is
extreme grete mm-hmm
you're putting our lives at risk for
your dogs no so on that note I'm gonna
side with that man
I will forever support that idea and
that sentiment that we have to put the
people's health hat at first like you
can't wait to do this kind of meeting
it's a very compelling video but what it
speaks to is the ineptitudes of some
local governments and being indecisive
and this segment is called why I do not
want to do politics I mean there's a lot
of things that we cannot talk about
there's a lot of secrecy there's a lot
just judging there's a lot of things you
have to keep secret you know I mean and
you're gonna look like the bad guy
regardless of whatever you say I mean if
you cannot be too transparent you know I
reflect on things you know I was talking
[ __ ] about the Prime Minister how he
took some time to and then I realize I
made some research and I really cuz I
was like so I was just like yeah but I
made some researches and I was like cuz
you said yeah but maybe you know maybe
he did and I'm based in research it's
actually what I was talking about
he should have closed the border he
couldn't close the border because he if
he closed the border or a lot of our
products that we had here are from the
states if they would oppose the broad
borders they would have closed
everything the products everything all
the trade they would have so it's like
America have us by the balls it's a bit
so that's why it takes more time and and
and that's a thing but he ends up
looking like he's not doing much all I'm
so not a fan of Trudeau but so just
shows you like how you can't divulge
everything and why you're doing certain
things or why you're not it's like
you're gonna look like a jackass
regardless if you take example from
Obama Obama a lot of people love Obama a
lot of black communities level Bhama and
stuff like that but you know I'm a bomb
people but I again and again there's
people yeah Obama bomb yeah right I
don't think you it was it was him it was
he was obligated to do so for some
reason that we don't know or whatever
you know what I mean there's a lot of
things that you cannot know and if you
try to work for the people it's just
weird how whatever you try to get
elected you sell this idea that you're
gonna work for the people but once
you're there everything takes so much
time that you cannot
past that there's like it takes too much
time to have an idea go from an idea to
actually monster to actions you know
what I mean there's a whole process that
you have to you have to go through this
guy was like well this guy I was though
we just seen the video was talking about
a meeting like that he wanted to have
the week before when everything could
have been when everything could have
been avoided I'd let it take so much
time to request for a meeting to having
me and the person on top is just may I
don't believe that it's you know I don't
believe if I don't believe that it's I
don't believe that there's a problem
we're not gonna hear you and that's
pretty much it I mean there's a lot of
there's too many rules there's too much
you can't be transparent too much rules
you're set in a box it's crazy really I
wouldn't want to engage in politics just
because of what I'm seeing there anyways
you did a good job my dude that's it
keep it up and get your flashlights
[Music]